we're expecting something a bit weird
something a bit wonderful um he tends to
play all sorts of openings i'll tell me
have he has ideas behind every specific
opening but it's very rarely a main line
it's very rarely something super direct
where the opponent just has to solve two
or three problems to be okay so uh
magnus i think won't have even prepared
too much uh from the black side against
artemis because artemis can open with
his king's pawn queen's pawn um any move
under the sun he does open with one d4
and we see black's knight come out i've
prepared for artemev recently at the
european team championships and i just
gave up after a while because he plays
every opening under the sun and uh simon
are we going to see harry the h pawn
push forward here
already that would be the chessable
course you've just made a big mistake
there ah so he doesn't go for it
yeah the grunfeld defense so a
counter-attacking opening by magnus
often giving white extra central pawns
but black will aim to challenge those
central pawns from the sides one of your
special specialities this is uh the
first opening i think you played wasn't
it and you still play it nowadays as
black and uh played by a lot of dynamic
players um gary kasparov played this a
lot and uh
yeah yeah mvl of course so it's a
counter-attacking opening uh for black
yeah yeah do you think it's a good
choice though to kind of play something
that's
quite dynamic and could potentially be
quite forcing i think against artemia
specifically it's a very very good
choice
that being said he does play himself as
black so um i mean i tell if he just
doesn't like his opponents to be direct
in the opening and the grunfeld is one
of the most direct
lines with lots of forcing variations so
i think against artemis specifically
maybe magnus has picked this line
and uh white's bishop coming out there
it's maybe not the main move usually we
see a trade of pawns in the center
but white's bishop coming out now
black's usual move is to plant the
knight in the center of the board it's
quite funny dave because i was looking
at this position recently for for my
last chess ball course i did with
richard palasa and um you can get the
same position but the pawns on h4 and h5
and then bishop g5 is actually a much
stronger move because your pawn on h4
protects the bishop so this knight jump
doesn't work as as effectively
in this one though black often gives up
a pawn to to get that bishop
and get very active chances and as you
say i think it's a it's a good choice
against artemia who's
someone who likes it quite calm i feel
he likes a nice slow approach to the
game uh so magnus changing his style
because that reason yeah now tamiya
playing a line that's very well known
but it is known to drift towards a level
type of end game so artemiev as you
mentioned simon liking things quieter at
least at the start of the game he likes
to build up and survive the opening
before uh putting the pressure on as the
game draws on so uh white's bishop
stepping back now i'm expecting to see a
night raid from magnus carlson
white bishop has lost a bit of time but
now there is pressure on black central
pawn so you need to trade a set of
knights
in order to relieve that tension yeah if
he does trade knights it's the main move
it's not the only move but uh it's
something that would be consistent with
what magnus carlsen played in 2012
against hikaru nakamura
so after the trader pawns and then i'm
expecting black to support the pawn in
the middle of the board and just pick up
his c pawn and move it one square oh
really that's the main line oh no it's
definitely not the main line no it's not
the main line it's what magnus did in
2012 okay so the main line is black sea
pawn pushing forward two squares
so
yeah maybe magnus in 2012 years ago
less familiar with the grinfeld in those
days um maybe he was just trying to take
his opponent out of theoretical waters i
would expect him to be a bit more direct
here how strong is like magnus's memory
because uh
at this level you know memory is is an
important part of being a good player
you have to
you know memorize all that theory that
you've learned over the years of playing
chess and
if you can't recall what you've worked
on like five years ago you can get a bad
position he's played the main move but
he he has i think quite famously this
incredible memory magnus right you've
seen that video that i did with with
magnus last year on his memory uh go to
chess24 if not and uh search magnus
class in memory yeah the memory test the
memory test oh incredible stuff yeah do
you think is that very unique magnus
carls in the memory test or is there
several players on this level that could
show us same kind of things to be honest
i think all the players at the top level
have a fantastic chess memory yeah i
mean we even see it with david here in
the studio you know you see how he's
like oh i've worked on this and then i
this is the main one i played this in
2001 i remember yeah right you know and
he doesn't and i i have the database in
front of me and he's like yes that was
this army yes but i i
my memory recall is not great is yours
great it's pretty okay actually it's
okay for long-term memory at least so
um yeah i mean there's a famous story of
magnus carson playing the
doing the reykjavik pub chess quiz okay
which i might have recalled before but
it was uh it's a famous quiz they play
at the reykjavik tournament still theory
on the board here where it's chess
related questions but not about your own
game extremely hard questions and you
have all these historians turn up for
this quiz and uh it's really really hard
and magnus won it pretty much on his own
with the highest score ever and some of
the questions he has been asked were so
obscure their positions from 300 years
ago between two players which no one had
heard of and he could name the players
name the position so
his his history uh and understanding and
uh the work he's put in and his recall
is is incredible and you know it shows
in the way it plays fantastic i think he
formed a team with uh john ludwig hammer
and they called it mc hammer
they did very well
[Laughter]
[Music]
can't touch this
meanwhile some traits on the board this
is still mainline theory as uh simon
mentioned this is still very well known
territory i've had this position
countless times myself uh from the black
side so two main moves is black uh white
has a strong hold in the center and you
want to challenge that so either you
bring the black knight out or you give
this check and this check normally
requires white to block it with a queen
we see a queen trade and the white king
in the center so this white king it
looks pretty strong because the queens
are off and it's already centralized
it's ready to join the action later on
but the black rooks will centralize and
hit that white king at some point so um
pros and cons behind having white's king
in the middle of the board i always
slightly prefer white's position in
these
lines just because the center is so
strong if you look at white's two
central pawns they protect each other
they're so hard to break down even if
you break them down it just leads to
exchanges and now i expect to see
white's king maybe take a step back
there we go off the line of the
blackrook and uh very balanced end game
in general it's just down to who knows
these positions better maybe and who can
come up with more creative ideas in this
end game yeah and i think it's kind of
clever the way um you know rtmf has
played this because he's facing a very
double-edged opening but he's managed to
get a position which he he likes playing
he likes playing these kind of positions
get the queens off play a more slower
approach to the game and it's very
important i feel when you have the white
pieces especially to take the game into
the kind of position you want to play
not even if you're getting an advantage
all the time but just a position you
enjoy playing and you're very good at
playing don't don't go tactical if you
you're not very good at calculating for
example and hear a very normal pawn push
you're trying to undermine black's two
pawns with your one pawn it's uh called
a minority attack this this idea
and it's a little bit more comfortable
and easier to play for white as you say
david i would feel here yeah i think
it's just there's more margin for error
as white even if things go really wrong
and black is able to push a pawn in the
center explode things open that will
just make the game fizzle out most
likely and as black if you're a bit
passive if you don't do too much then
white does have ideas as simon mentioned
this minority attack maybe white can
start pushing forward on the other side
of the board as well with some pawns
it's uh less clear what black should be
doing meanwhile magnus stops any
potential pawn push to further open up
those white rooks by planting tonight on
the side of the board and usually we say
nights on the rimmer dim but this is
very typical for the grunfeld defense
that black knight is actually
technically on an outpost supported by
pawn as well so on a decent square and
is also preventing white from marching
the a pawn up one square just to
initiate simon's plan of attack and this
is why there's only one game in my
database uh between two grand masters um
melchy man and chaparrinov and in that
game white actually rerouted the knight
and put it on d2 in order to initiate a
trade
so black's knight just doing a great job
of blocking up this whole left side of
the board um so the move ivanka
mentioned that has been played before is
this knight retreat going to this square
or this one to get rid of this night and
uh that trade
i guess it benefits white slightly but
then again material coming off the board
does mean a draw is the most likely
result and uh what happened in that game
your anchor
draw it was a draw okay so um other
plans for white could include uh i mean
just having studied similar positions to
this one not this exact position similar
plans could include just maybe gaining
space on this king side on the right
side of the board
for example you could try and challenge
now for the open file that uh once
black's knight has abandoned it um
i'm trying to think what else you could
possibly do as white i would be inclined
if you want the nitrate to go to a more
central square like this one
okay he does go for the move that has
been played before and knight retreat
so will this nitrate favor white that is
the big question black's bishop on a
long diagonal actually both of black's
bishops are on long diagonals right now
but they will be blocked by pawns most
likely and this pawn is attacked by
black's bishop from afar
are we going to lift it up the board
yeah and in the game uh why it got very
well i say very
ambitious and
lifted up two squares yeah and we've
mentioned him a couple of times already
since you've arrived simon but keith
arkell a friend of ours grandmaster and
endgame expert loves this type of pawn
push i think he said it's his favorite
favorite move
he said if you can ever play this move
as black so if you can ever play the
same move that white's played here then
black's always doing okay because it's
kind of a luxury to be able to play such
a move uh in a position it means you
have time it means you can just gain
some space and space is very important
uh in chess because you want to cramp
your opponent's position and that seems
that seems like a a very sensible move
to play yeah and he has played it he has
played it and especially i've noticed
when you're playing against this pawn
structure it's especially effective
because now it's far less attractive for
a black to ever push this pawn two
squares or push this pawn two squares
because things would open up in white's
favor and yeah it just clamps down and
later on you might push this pawn
forward and then you're very flexible
you could clamp down even further with
this pawn or you can open up lines with
harry the h pawn here it's just a very
nice pawn structure for white on the
other side of the board black has the
advantage with this two versus one but
that's very much a long term thing
that's only going to come into effect
later in the game short term white's
pawn so maybe more mobile
and uh in the meantime magnus i'm pretty
sure he's going to bring his rook to the
open file i would just play that without
thinking to be honest i don't see what
else
yeah that's exactly what happened in the
game i have in my database
and white actually challenged
the rook because of course you can't
just allow black to have this amazing
rook controlling the open line and
from here white played actually quite a
crafty move and uh tried to take control
of the c line by actually
posting his bishop onto the c7 square
okay so it's black's move first what did
black play
uh ivanka oh sorry i'm sorry sorry i
missed a move uh he played a poor move
which is f6
it's nearly nearly e5 as a tactic it's
the kind of move you have to watch out
for with uh some idea at some point of
getting the the open line
and a tactic against the knight
it doesn't quite work here but you've
got to watch out for pawn breaks and
okay magnus preparing that pawn break
and we're still following the game yeah
which which is a little bit remarkable
actually um i wonder if do you think
they're aware of this game um or they're
just playing uh the standard kind of
moves you would do in such position
feeling that they might not be aware of
the game it's just standard moves
yeah this is all i mean this opening
often leads to these types of positions
and okay we do see the first novelty of
the game so finally branching away from
that previous example between two
grandmasters that ivanka mentioned
instead of bringing the bishop forward
which is a very typical idea actually in
this opening uh just dislodging the
black rook and trying to at least block
uh this open line white has instead
pushed a pawn and
he's trying to undermine black's
structure here it makes some sense
because this is the side white is
stronger white has a pawn advantage
these four are less impressive than
white pawns but then again
i don't know it does feel a bit loose
somehow and some calculation needs to be
done for example whether black can break
forward in the center
uh
what do we think guys do we like this
move i i mean if e5 doesn't work uh this
this break that black is trying to play
then i think it's a great move because
you're just trying to stop black's
counterplay playing you want to maybe
just simply capture black's pawn uh rule
out this this break forever uh so i
guess e5 you have to play it now if
you're going to get active i mean
so if e5 works for black maybe it's not
good move but if it doesn't work great
move i'd say uh here so um yeah i mean i
guess white just wants to play pawn
takes pawn and um then
has a great pass pawn on the d file if
uh if white if black recaptures that one
just for example yeah if we see a trade
of pawns then this guy is rock-solid but
also later gonna march down the board
unrivalled so key moment for magnus is
he going to push this pawn forward it's
either very good or very bad but now is
potentially the moment
he's gone back he goes back wow
surprising i don't like that one he's
just hoping for a trade now and then
he's hoping to bring his bishop this way
uh to maybe pin in the knight and go
towards the white king but it's very
slow and it is reliant on white being
a bit submissive here and just saying
okay i'll do what you want pawn takes
pawn i mean another another very
tempting idea for white here to be able
to use the light square bishop because i
just want to stop this one break black
has take the counter play out so if i
brought that bishop to attack the rook
uh i'm trying to uh well i'm probably
forcing you now to move that pawn you've
just moved one square forwards and i
rule out your your main break in the
position because i have total control
simply come back and um i think i've
gained quite a lot from this as in my
position now is nice and solid you don't
have any pawn breaks and yeah i can keep
playing and playing and playing here
yeah i guess magnus here would be forced
to push this pawn forward at least he
activates this bishop on a different
diagonal and um i agree i slightly
prefer white and i think this is
profited white this uh this whole
transition but
then again black is still solid for now
and it is hard for white to push these
pawns forward they'll always get taken
off the board so a tense position and uh
let's go back to the players is this uh
is it going to be interesting now to see
if artemia will sort of
join magnus's plan and uh trade off
these pawns or or if it's gonna maybe go
for the win is another move going for
the win i think he wants to go for the
win in general whether he takes that
pawn or not um
i wouldn't take that pawn just because
my mindset in every chess game is if i
know why my what my opponent wants i'll
do the opposite i'll try and frustrate
them at every opportunity and i doubt
we'll see white take that black pawn off
the board it just feels like it's giving
magnus what he wants but uh yeah it's
just about whether he finds an effective
move maybe he'll go for similar plans to
the one simon mentioned there or maybe
he'll just maintain the status quo by i
don't know pushing a pawn on the side of
the board pushing harry up the board it
all depends on whether black's pawn
break the one we highlighted is
effective or not and
possibly it is a threat and uh in that
case artemia needs to do something
i mean you could play a tactical idea
here as well with bishop to b5 are going
the other way and i want to play an idea
that uh ivanka mentioned was played in
this grand master game of trying to uh
trying to trap the black rook uh with
just using the bishop pair bishop pair's
incredibly powerful and open open
structures and uh this at least creates
uh what i think is a threat um which
asks ask your opponent a question
um so that's that's that's what he's
thinking about now i quite like that
move actually because you know if black
reacts say for instance by attacking
that light square bishop after all the
bishop is on black side of the board
we know we always say give it a kick
exactly give a boot exactly but you know
those poor moves have consequences once
the bishop just returns even maybe back
to its original square
and now the idea of actually playing the
bishop to attack the rook it's going to
be really dead it's going to be really
dangerous
yeah yeah it looks looks like a nice
idea i mean we're neglecting black's
plans though and black does have one
idea in the position in the current
position and that is this pawn push and
it all depends for example if the white
bishop moves whether say we trade off
first whether this move is effective or
not it looks like a pawn sacrifice but
if the pawn is captured suddenly there's
stuff to work out this is a very scary
pin yeah and uh not just that but if the
knight is defended then the black knight
can jump in
trying to overwhelm this night there's a
check yeah there is a check so maybe
there's maybe it's just not a threat at
the moment maybe it is who knows i mean
even this check i mean it's scary i'm
not scared of this to be honest
it's very very complicated here and
that's why the players are spending so
much time on the clock yeah so it could
turn like on those kind of yeah accurate
moves and again i think artemis is doing
something very clever here that when
you're playing and this is maybe one of
the mistakes eric hansen didn't quite do
in his game so if you in a game of chess
you generally only have about what the
top players would say four or five
critical moments
and they're the moments where you have
to use your time if you have an obvious
move then there's no point thinking for
ages you play a move but in this
position we're seeing it's very complex
in the position the result could all
turn on this moment of the game so you
spend your spend the time you have use
that time and work out these critical
moments as best you can so i think i
think he's doing doing time uh using his
time very very wisely here yeah and
that's one thing we haven't said
actually that much of our temperature
throughout the champions chess tour
using his time wisely but he was four
minutes up on the clock compared to
magnus and now he's invested around four
minutes so time is roughly level now and
uh yeah as you mentioned simon it is a
critical moment so now is the moment to
spend that time i'm expecting him to
speed up uh over the next few moves once
he does stumble across a plan he likes
and if you at home have any move
suggestions any ques test questions
you'd like to ask us then remember to
tweet us using the hashtag chesstamps
thank you yeah okay he does jump in so
one of the ideas we mentioned
and uh black's rook is under attack now
the c file is plugged it's blocked and
this bishop will most likely get kicked
away though and will have to retreat
yeah i think you can't move the rook to
the side because it gets attacked by the
bishop so you have to uh create a threat
here and is is rtmf's idea
obviously he could go through a draw but
you can't do that in the match situation
but is his idea to bring the bishop back
to a better square slightly improving so
that's the only
only idea i can see and just say okay
i'm just just trying to make some very
slight improvements but is the bishop
really better after well it could be
because uh it doesn't mean when black
makes the ideal pawn break yeah it
doesn't attack the bishop so this is
actually a very free move this is very
subtle so we could show this maybe david
if the rook comes up one square
attacking the bishop then white's idea
could be to move the bishop all the way
back
and let's now say magnus moves the rook
back again to try to keep control of the
open file now maybe this this bishop
well there's other options here because
your break david this very clever break
doesn't have a tempo for black it's
incredibly subtle stuff uh which you
have to work out but yeah yeah it's
possibly a very clever idea yeah so just
to explain this pawn push doesn't hit
the bishop anymore so small difference
as you mentioned it's these tiny little
sudden subtleties nuances and just
having this bishop on a slightly better
square or safer square than it
previously
stood on might make all the difference
wow i mean
in a rapid game to see these tiny little
details is incredibly impressive and uh
maybe it's effective maybe it's not but
either way uh kudos to artemiev for
uh for at least going for this type of
idea then again let's hope that he tries
to play for the win because as mentioned
once magnus does lift the rook up the
board he could just repeat moves by
bringing the bishop back to this one um
i have a feeling though that you guys
are right he's going to try on uh try
and play on for the win yeah and then
the other one uh game two in between
essie panko and then bomnier the bar has
just completely shut off for janna
pomnyacci he still has
15 minutes left on the clock gezipanko
has 10 minutes left on the clock but
something must have happened in that
game yeah it just does look like a
one-move blunder by essepenko and he
just underestimated his king safety as
he did in the first game today and the
pogbachie simon mentioned he's he's so
tuned into his opponent's king and he
has found a really really nice tactic uh
maybe we'll get time to show that later
because probably actually found a
beautiful move uh meanwhile this game
has gone as predicted it's not a
repetition of moves this is just the
same position as earlier but white's
dark squared bishop is on a slightly
safer square
so uh yeah very sticky and another
critical point here i mean white white
if he wants to win has to now uh find a
plan again he's improved his position a
little bit but he still has to uh
do something here i expect it will be
to do with the light square bishop his
other bishop where is he going to place
that uh that that looks like the kind of
obvious thing to try
i mean there's other options you could
just slip the rook in the corner over
one square
just play it very calmly
stop um some of black's pieces
potentially coming in that looks like a
sensible move
as well maybe maybe black can take your
pawn but it's
something you could consider yeah that's
a good question actually whether black
is even threatening to take that white
pawn um if you look at the g5 square
white's pawn that is hanging but if
black ever takes it then black's pawn
structure becomes very ugly
um you know what black would lose a lot
of central control so
that that's unclear whether that's a
threat and artemis probably trying to
work out whether that's the issue but
just from his body language i'll tell
you of leaning back a bit
you know i've seen that before i've
played him a few times over the board
and that normally means that he's not in
love with his position and if he's not
in love with this position he will feel
a bit of temptation to repeat and bring
his bishop back what's your score
against uh alton i mean he's he's
incredibly strong but that's quite good
actually i think i'm plus one i think
quite good that's that's that's a plus
how modest are you quite good i'm just
i'll just beat him
so how many times you played him one i
hope three three times okay there's two
drawers in one win it's very impressive
and magnus you you have because
obviously
childhood friends with him and uh
your score against him minus two so six
drawers just minus two six draws and two
losses i think that's that's very
impressive that's enormous so i need my
revenge i just want one win in a
classical game against him yeah and then
i'll retire happy
as your friends do you do do you think
uh you know if you did if you did beat
him in a classical game do you think
he'd take that well
i mean i probably wouldn't talk to me
for seven years
he still says that uh
well so i guess he didn't play you but
when
was that 2003
worst chess experience of my life is
what he said
yeah after my game against him in the
final round yeah the world under 12
championship in 2002 yeah well you won
then i and i wasn't uh he needed to beat
me exactly to get the gold medal yeah
and actually he was better throughout
the whole game but i managed to defend
an unpleasant end game
but actually our next two games after
that i had a big big advantage
and one of the position one of the games
i agreed to draw i didn't realize i had
a winning move i just didn't see it and
i only had 30 seconds on the clock so i
took the draw but
i'll never forget that he's one win
against him would have been
i imagine boasting about that for the
rest of my life
missed opportunity well was he already
back then so we're talking 2003 um the
the big name among young players in in
the world actually um a few others uh
napoli actually was maybe regarded as
the bigger talent um napoli actually won
several gold medals in these youth
events magnus never won a gold actually
in any youth uh world or european event
so napoli actually won several golds
another russian player and draken uh won
several golds
back then vashey legrav was regarded as
very good sergey karyakin um he kind of
he played a couple of times but then he
kind of bypassed all the youth events
because he was already a grandmaster at
12. that's true um so
yeah too many big names
magnus was one of the bunch just like
now we see a whole group of players uh
like esopenko like pregnant like ferugia
and it's nice to see a whole generation
come through and it will be fascinating
to see which one of the group emerges as
the top dog yeah like magnus did yeah
and who gets into top ten in the world
it's gonna be interesting to see our
time you have 23 where has he turned 24
yeah
good question yeah okay but i think he
is 23 our time same generation uh same
born in the same year as the young
christian duda so those two have been
fighting it out and then we have
essipanko who is only 19
and coming behind him of course we have
alerts russia and then you have
issenheimer
and
i'm just a tour of 17 i mean
and they're all roughly the same age
right 16 17 yeah
of course yeah and i it somehow works
like that in the chess world you know
like 1990 was a golden year for future
chess grand masters and it seems to be
the case with those who are 17 16 year
olds because they're so strong now it's
2003 2004 there's a whole bunch right uh
so yeah
new generation they're rising especially
in this tournament and uh meanwhile a
move from our tamiya do you like this
one simon white offering a trade of
lifespan bishops i
i do actually in in it's a very simple
approach and it kind of uh i guess suits
artillery of style that he wants simple
advantages he's uh he's really good at
grinding i mean i i i would say
his style and magnus's style are quite
similar in the way that um they both
prefer a small grind you know a small
advantage magnus is much more versatile
so you can play any position so i can
already move but uh magnus is a better
way this just aiming to swap off black's
bishop which is crossing the board in a
powerful way
and you know bringing the knight towards
a good square uh it makes it's a logical
move it makes a lot of sense so it can't
it can't be a bad move for sure and at
least he's trying to play for a win yeah
i have to say the assignment that i'm
actually not a fan
and i'm not a fan for a concrete reason
i just think that after bishop takes
bishop
and
the knight is forced to capture that
bishop and then i'm just like well you
know one of the key things about open
lines is that if you control
the bottom row then you can kind of in
this particular case it's the c1 square
you control the line so i'm thinking the
knight can just hop in
so a double attack against the white
rooks you don't win anything because
after rook takes rook black has to
recapture but now as uh i guess the idea
is yes you might have to take a step
back but you've controlled yeah it's
open line and that for me
is a
small
small delight yeah
the lights are the best aren't they in
life sometimes um i i mean yeah it's
it's it's certainly again because you've
gained the open file i mean i'm
wondering if white will now be able to
bring his king towards the center safely
and you know slowly
slowly improve um he's got such a great
king now in these positions the white
king compared to the black king and in
the ending the king is a credibly
powerful piece so if i can just bring
that king up another square
and then you know just
start start pushing my pawns um forwards
my bishop is much better than the black
bishop your knight is on the edge of the
board um it seems like i i prefer to be
white at least here's still
um it's going to become very okay we
might be headed in that direction but
it's going to become very very sharp so
i agree with everything you said there
simon but black does have counter play
so for example the rook could come and
target this weak pawn there's actually
no real way to defend it i don't think
you can really put your rook in the
corner and walk into some night checks
some calculation to be done here maybe
it's possible but it's a bit scary so we
might see a situation where white just
abandons this pawn on the side of the
board and uh for example marches the
king up starts pushing these pawns
forward and uh or maybe even white now
takes control over the open line and
tries to infiltrate into black's camp
onto the seventh rank h6 is a wow is it
is it well a move i would not consider i
agree
i mean this is this is is this a world
champion move i mean i i just wouldn't
look at that side of the board
you know i'd be blinkered by the the the
moves that uh
that ivanka has suggested um i mean this
knight jump was so yeah
and
obviously yeah so i guess this pawn push
he just wants to eliminate as many pawns
as possible on the side of the board so
for example if white steps up and guards
this pawn then maybe trading these
things off magnus is thinking okay
uh just slightly closer to safety more
pawns are leaving the board but then
again it does look slow right and uh
once it's not clear which point you
capture right and one thing that i'm
afraid of is like you know if we're just
quickly in our minds do a comparison of
the lines that simon mentioned and you
mentioned about the white king going
active in the middle of the board just
imagine that situation and white has a
pawn on h6 the black king can never ever
join the action and i say that because
white can play pawn takes pawn
at which pawn are you thinking uh the h6
pawn okay and black will recapture i
guess yeah
and uh yeah at least the black bishop
now is just staring against the granite
really right it's not going to break
through on this diagonal it will have to
reroute itself later on back where it
came from maybe
so yeah surprising that white didn't go
for that i would be tempted to go the
other way as well just because i like
having a past pawn in the center of the
board and now maybe bring the king up
but um
i'll tell you how to choose indeed to
just support his pawns we do go for this
exact line we showed earlier just with
these pawn pushes included
yeah and in the other one jana pomnyacci
has now won game two with the black
pieces against desi panko that means
nepomniachi is up by
one point after two games
and the next one will start in about 14
minutes sesipenko he has now two rapid
games and he has to win at least one of
them
and if he does
it's going to go to thai breaks but
nepalniacci up by one point same as
magnus carlsen he won the first game
do you see big chances for ezepenko in
this game to definitely to make a
comeback definitely yeah i mean i think
he's got if you ask him before the game
and i always think this when you look at
position you ask the player would you
like this position for the game and i
think his answer would be yes i take
this position 99 times out 100 against
magnus i mean i i am a little bit
worried about david's idea of black
using that activity with the rook but if
i can somehow neutralize that one idea
then positionally speaking white is just
better he's got better pieces better
center and um you know black's queen
side pawns are on dark squares you have
a dark square bishop there's there's
some problems in the ending so i i i
think he would take this ending would
would you agree with that i mean but
with this position before the game yeah
i mean maybe white doesn't have a huge
advantage or anything but stylistically
it's his type of position right uh i'll
tell you okay he brings his rook to the
center very surprised by that because
why not at least push that knight to
what seems to me a more passive square
um i don't know the knight on b3 seem
it scares me a little bit um i'd rather
put that on the side of the ball before
playing move like this and it also stops
the white king uh yeah going forward
maybe but uh just to
kind of push the point i'll tell you
have in end games uh we've seen that
ancient stats are very similar but end
games he's one of the best players on
the tour so
in general he will trust himself in
these types of positions and i have to
say when it comes to end games and time
travel he is fantastic you know he will
calculate everything out incredibly
quickly and uh i have to say i was a
little bit impressed by his rick move it
looked odd didn't come to mind but i you
know it was kind of based on the fact
that i think he had in his mind this
idea of actually capturing the f6 pawn
and maybe generating a very very strong
past deep one and that's why i guess
magnus has replied not by being greedy
not by bringing the black rook in but by
using the black king that black king
wants to act as a blockader for this
white pawn that has just pushed forward
yeah i'm not i'm not convinced by this
plan because i mean
let's say black centralizes the night
now or something i mean i love pushing
my opponent's pieces to basques he just
uh uh i mean what about this knight now
coming he has moved the night back so
i don't know i mean that night was
certainly
on a much worse square a while back um
yeah i mean you could have had that same
position but with black's knight on the
edge of the board right yeah maybe that
was more effective so
yeah you can't you can't slip up against
magnus this is the thing even if you get
a position which is very playable
it's so hard because you make one i
don't know if it was a slight error but
one he just grabs all the opportunity
opportunities uh that are given to him
and uh i don't know is this is this
is this okay now for black i mean it
felt like a position where white was
very very safe just a few times ago now
it feels like all three results are
possible right because black is hitting
this white pawn on the side of the board
the white a pawn is isolated undefended
black's knight can even go towards the
center go towards the white bishop um
centralizing centralizing that piece
exactly
white's lost a lot of control and
unfortunately the move that white really
wants to play here is actually to
move the rook to the sea line and
perhaps pin the knight on the rook but
that is impossible because knight
to d3 would be an unpleasant uh night
fork that's a big understatement
unpleasant that's a very english way of
saying a disaster you know
absolute disaster yeah a little bit
unpleasant you know yeah oh it's raining
today and it's actually pouring yeah
that's correct
i'm very guilty of doing the british
understatement
british thing i think isn't it talking
of slightly unpleasant look at the clock
time for i'll tell you now oh that is
wow yeah earlier he was actually four or
five minutes ahead on the clock uh
compared to magnus just after the
opening stage but now he's really
spending too much time and he's also
made the position more complicated as we
mentioned so now white's rook has lifted
up the board uh we always see these
swinging rooks and the last few days of
the knockouts but white's rook is
defending the white pawn on the side of
the board but look at this black's
bishop now going back to its original
diagonal
indirectly attacking this white rook in
the center if black can push upon and
open up that black bishop black is doing
great so we see a pawn trade which way
oh is uh is magnus gonna capture bishop
or porn it's tempting to capture with a
bishop but then i think pawn takes
maintain the porn integrity so white has
a passport now the white d-pawn and the
grunfeld is all about that pawn
i remember reading jonathan rousey's
book on the grindfeld when i was young
understanding the greenfield and he
named that deepon delroy and it was all
about whether it's a strength or
weakness and it's never clear
so either white has a very good strong
past pawn in the middle of the wood or a
big target for black's pieces later yeah
that's that's actually where i stole the
idea for harry from really it was dale
rice so which certainly certainly wasn't
my own idea you shouldn't mention that
it's how you coined it copyright
did he call it harry
um no he came up with naming the pawns
after certain things in this great book
on the grunfeld which uh which was his
main opening and uh yes i mean we spoke
about this yesterday this this isolated
pawn and it it is actually an isolated
pawn as well but it's also a pass pawn
so it's really like double edged is it a
game winner or will it drop off the
board and maybe that's what uh the
position will hinge around at the moment
uh that that one pawn but the time
okay
magnus having a good think here but
artemis got to gotta pick up the pace
and it feels like white already has to
find some really tricky moves i mean
that rook lift white lifting the rook up
the board that wasn't obvious it cost on
time we have some time now pushing his
king up the board looks very healthy but
it's not going to be clear whether there
might be some checks against that king
later that king's journey might not go
much further so there's a lot to think
about for white how to improve the white
minor pieces of the knight the bishop
which looked okay but actually can't
jump anywhere uh effective so lots of
questions for a time we have to answer
and now okay it's surprising magnus
brings his knight back but then again it
does block that pawn we've been talking
about white's far advanced deformed and
black's rook has suddenly opened up
uh
yeah personally i quite like that
actually also some threats of black
pushing the f pawn out the way opening
up the black bishop uh to attack the
white rook
yes sorry i was just going to say that i
like it because of its surprise value
you know artemis really doesn't have
much time on the clock and he would have
been like oh what how do i handle that
it also controls this of a square in the
middle of the board the the e5 square
which now um white may have had a chance
to move the knight into the center uh
had had black had magnus not retreated
uh they said retreating night moves the
hardest moves to see right and magnus
blundered earlier on the tournament uh
against eric hansen when he missed a
retreating night move he could have done
this so uh yeah they're very hard to see
it's not natural to move your knights
backwards well tell me if coolly playing
his move with eight seconds despite he's
a cool guy
well he's used to these uh time troubles
right we remember them definitely from
last season he's not called the iceman
for nothing yeah he's the ice man but
another unexpected move from magnus
carlsen not trading rooks immediately
he's saying yes the rooks can come off
the board but it's going to be on my
terms and blacks rook attacking the
white central pawn i'll tell you going
down under 10 seconds again he's just
given up a pawn uh what a move he's just
pushing a pawn forward now if black's
rook goes and takes this white central
pawn that we've been talking about so
much white's rook will be able to get up
to the seventh rank and start hitting
some things so it's amazing seeing the
body language between rtmf and espnko
because if espnko is in this position
he'd be bouncing around he'd be so
active
our teammate is just you know having he
just looks like he's going to fall
asleep in a minute you know he's got
he's got 10 as well 20 seconds left now
incredibly cool
but this this seems like a pretty
awesome move to play with so little time
because you you have to give up pawn but
you've got you're trying to get your
work to a much more active square i
guess is uh it's his plan at least uh if
if black takes the pawn
in the middle of the board there and the
big question for magnus do you take this
white pawn now but allow your opponent's
pieces to get active because if you
don't take it now white is going to push
another pawn in the center of the board
and unite these two central pawns where
it's e-pawn d-pawn they'll start
marching so magnus shaking his head
there it's a huge decision i don't think
it's i don't think he's shaking his head
because he's unhappy i think it's just
because it's a confusing situation and
uh not one he expected he was trying to
uh kind of trick artemyev now artemis so
long time but he's the one being tricked
and look at this
what uh white central pawn did indeed
disappear but that white rook on the
seventh rank very very strong and at the
minimum white can just go and recapture
rapport now take that a pawn i would do
it immediately actually yeah i think so
just get rid of that poor majority that
black has and uh you know again you okay
he has played that
it looks like especially with magnus's
last move swapping more pieces off
we might be heading towards a draw
in this position it looks it looks very
likely to me especially if those two a
pawns drop off if they get traded which
i think they quite likely will white's
going after this black pawn black going
after the white pawn
if it's just pawns on one side of the
board it's nearly definitely going to be
a draw and there we see for two nights a
bit of symmetry there they do go and
grab those pawns
yeah and there's a life left really now
no and i think you can see it in
magnus's face sometimes when he knows
the game sort of uh drifted off into a
draw um and
it seems like a very fair result
actually the way the game's gone yeah
fair play to tell me if he tried
something it didn't really work out uh
maybe because he spent too much time on
the clock and lost a bit of control but
uh yeah also fabulated magnus who
defended very well and just very calmly
yeah
yeah and draw looks like a fair result
actually just a very high quality game
right i think a very good game yeah both
players say very accurate i would say
yeah from magnus especially yeah some
really nice moves
that means it's going to be still up by
one point magnus carlsen after two games
artemiev
he has two more rapid games to make that
comeback he needs a win to take it to
tie breaks
and the magnus will have the white
pieces in the next game
oh down to three seconds
really keeping us on edge and what's he
doing he's just giving up a pawn
is this necessary he's he's showing off
now yeah i mean uh it might still be a
draw but why go for this makes no sense
chances for magnus now yeah definitely
it's just you don't need to give up a
pawn like this right yeah incredible i
mean it was just completely leveled i
mean this is yeah i mean this is kind of
plain magnus and you're like i'm just
going to give myself some pain because
uh yeah i i don't understand that at all
i'm pretty sure it's going to be a draw
because if you look at black's corner
pawn so black has a two versus one
advantage now with pawns but if you look
at black's h-pawn and you if you look at
where it wants to promote it promotes on
a light square so
even if white say the knights come off
the board even if white gives up his
bishop and his pawn for black's
remaining g pawn then white can just
park the king in the corner on the light
square we saw this yesterday actually
napoli just parking your king on the op
and in the corner square on the opposite
color to your opponent's bishop is
enough to draw so there is still some
leeway despite what the computer says
right now artemis should still draw this
game just by planting the white king in
the corner of the board uh later on if
he needs to that's why magnus keeps the
knights on the board how about the clock
time is it hard for artemiv to do that
with so little time on the clock well
now the knights are on the board i think
it's going to be a difficult task for
him you know he's more than capable of
holding this position but he has made a
bit of a mountain out of a molehill in
this defense
still a draw but he would love to get
the knights off he would love to just
park the white king
near his pawn and it should just be a
fortress a dead draw but
now still some hard work to be done
knights are so tricky as well
i mean you can re-route this knight to
attack the h-pawn um and the bishop can
attack the h pawns so black can
potentially get both of his pieces
attacking white's remaining pawn and
that could really tie down uh white and
the other thing is you can play this
position on forever now and before you
never give your opponent a pawn for free
in an ending even if it is a draw just
just uh just torturing yourself and um
that's what he's doing here in the past
in uh in last season of the tour we
talked about the magnus effect this
feels like the magnus effect
any other opponent in the world artemis
would have just played that end game it
was about to fizzle out to a draw he
wouldn't have cared but then he just
wanted to force it he wanted to force
the draw immediately but he gave up a
pawn in the process so unnecessary and
magnus knows it should still be a draw
with best play that's why magnus's body
language is still pretty relaxed but if
he smells blood if he sees the game
continue to move in black's favor the
momentum on his side then
we could well be seeing another 50 moves
of torture well we can see yeah that
this white pawn is on a dark square and
he's magnus is now starting to target it
it takes his night two moves to target
white's pawn as well and um
i i could certainly see uh white losing
this this one actually yeah um it's it's
unpleasant and uh what about if the
bishops get traded off because uh magnus
now has a possibility of doing he hasn't
done it i think yeah you can take the
bishops off the board at any moment
later in the game anyway so there's no
need to rush the black knight is going
towards this white corner pawn
and uh there we go a big threat against
white's remaining pawn it's isolated
it's weak if you defend it with the
white knight now the black king comes in
oh this one is hanging by a thread for
yeah i'll tell you
yeah he's made it so so tricky here i
don't i mean i don't know if you take
the bishop you probably you don't need
to wait with it right yeah yeah you can
bring the blackberry you can get your
king into the game yeah and suddenly it
looks incredibly scary yeah and magnus
has got three minutes to enjoy his
position
uh i'll tell you have seconds yeah
compare the kings white's king is
paralyzed stuck defending the pawn in
front of it black's king has a free run
it's going to dislodge the white knight
first and then the black king is going
to move over slowly towards the white
king gonna try and trap it on the edge
of the two seconds one second wow oh
with one second left on the clock oh
brinksmanship
okay and black's king could have
attacked both pieces at the same time
there but white king could have defended
them just it's just really he's clinging
on by his fingernails to this game now
tell me evan
i'm still so shocked he gave up that
pawn earlier uh still so much five
seconds just wondering what he missed
there i i'm really wondering what i'll
tell you i've missed to give up
maybe just a blooper or something yeah
miss evaluation i think yeah he thought
it would be a simple draw just get rid
of pawns but no down to three seconds
four seconds again black's king is
coming in
this is really uncomfortable now for for
uh for whites he's getting uh pushed
around all over shop and white's pieces
and such bad squares maybe
yeah i mean is there a killer blow i
don't know but it's it's it's
uncomfortable it's close you're nelly
and zugswang in
meaning that white's going to run out
moves potentially at some point
in this position
maybe black needs to relocate the knight
round now somewhere better so it can
check away the white king
it's still not easy for magnus to find
the killer blow he's black's pieces are
all on perfect squares but white has set
up a defensive fortress in a way so okay
he brings his bishop in
white's knight really lacking squares
actually white's knight looks great but
he can't join the action again it can't
go towards where all the pawns lie black
cutting off all the squares
how many times have you seen magnus win
positions like this so
many i've seen i've seen it do it so
many times where everyone thinks it's a
draw and all of a sudden he will just
play improve play wait for a weakness
wait for a blunder win
and uh he's he he loves winning these
kind of kind of ones i mean you're even
looking at a checkmate pattern in in
some structures if you can three seconds
two seconds one second is he lost at all
he did it with two seconds left like
knight e to get the bishop hitting h2
knight g1 checkmate is one very powerful
idea i mean the white king don't go for
the h-bomb go for checkmate here why not
knight e2 looks incredibly dangerous
yeah exactly white's king lacking
squares if the knight goes back slightly
surprising that one
as you mentioned simon that was so
tempting at least threatened the idea of
checkmate and
uh okay instead
now white's knight has centralized so
maybe slightly uh better set up
defensively i've got still the same idea
in the air you know the white king
doesn't have too many squares
and artemia is just reduced to moving
his knight to random squares yep and if
he just checks the king with the black
knight is checkmate now so okay it takes
a while to get there but if you can do
that whilst white can't improve his
position um is checkmate so you know
just pick up the black knight and yes on
f2 or g1 checkmate but maybe this is a
bad circuit actually for the white
knight
knight might get trapped by the black
bishop black bishop could just take a
step back maybe
but i'm also thinking in terms of checks
okay it's not that easy for black he's
going for it he gets actually yeah the
knight
the knight is just trying to get into
position where it checks the white king
and that is checkmate so okay so he
probably he has to move the bishop right
yeah
bishop jumping out the way so the white
knight can occupy the square it
previously stood on with a check you
need to kick away the black king the
black king has completely boxed in its
counterpart its rival there still so
calm isn't he artem
i just cool but okay look okay we have
checkmate in the air it's a fret knight
g1 okay
one yeah there's only two ways to stop
that either you give a check to the
black king or you bring the white bishop
back to cover any potential checking
squares from the black knight two
seconds only two possible moves to stop
checkmate
he gives a check himself unbelievable i
can't believe he looks so calm
and again he's making the move with
three seconds to spare he's defending
incredibly well considering the the
circumstances here so yeah fantastic
defense but still on the brink just
that's the thing
one slip and it's going to end in
checkmate white's king is trapped
so
he has to keep doing this for many many
more moves um if i'm just going to check
as well while the game continues while
white knight hits the black bishop i'm
going to check how many moves he needs
to survive to make the 50 move rule okay
now there's an exchange of pieces
possibly but this is choice for artemia
does he rock the boat
and make the trade or does he kind of
maintain the same situation and he's
just chosen to maintain the same peace
formation so it's gonna be knight and
bishop because knight and bishop and he
steps back with his king
but
maybe missing an opportunity there yeah
black needs to keep the night alive to
win the game but in that type of
position it's a fine line right between
a draw and a loss artemis just didn't
have enough time to calculate whether
trading a night for the black bishop was
beneficial for him so we continue we're
going to go round in a bit of a circle
here the last pawn move was on move 44.
so they've made 24 moves okay halfway
yeah 24 moves without a capture and
without a pawn push if it's 50 moves so
if there's no capture or pawn push
before black's 94th move it's a draw
okay
94. 94 is the magic number yep all right
yeah david i have a question for you
about how emotionally draining is it to
play always on the brink of time defeat
it's exhilarating your vancouver get
full of adrenaline you're this is why
you do it because i mean david you're
you're quite famous for doing a similar
thing to ultimate rtmf here like
getting down to your last couple of
seconds playing a move getting down to
your last couple of seconds playing a
move did you do it for a rush or do you
do it because you just end up in that
situation you're maybe a bit of a
perfectionist and you're trying to find
the best moves for out yeah i think when
i was younger i did it for the rush just
because i enjoyed the situation but the
older i get the i mean it's more
stressful now i can't my nerves aren't
the same as they used to be okay we see
a trade so no more 50 move rule um but
yeah i was just going to say it's become
more of a habit now a bad habit but i
need to kick
time travel is definitely a sin
at home and you simon do you i mean when
i'm in this kind of situation with
seconds left on the clock i feel
incredibly stressed do you feel i i i
can't handle it i mean i i just
you know i've got enough bad habits as
it is i don't need any more so you know
uh but i i love the rush i mean i love
blitz chess over the board and i i do
you know the agenda is incredible yeah
but um i i don't play very well when i'm
short of time i'm not particularly good
at calculating quickly like david is oh
hang on a second
okay the bishops have come off so black
meets his knight
okay oh no no this is a blunder i think
white's inside so i think what one
knight can't move it's that trick swag
no matter what what it does now his
position will worsen if the white king
moves the black king comes across and
takes the white pawn if the white knight
moves the white knight is getting
trapped
oof
sneaky
incredible incredible i mean i thought
the piece is exchanged off that's nearer
to a draw next move losing
i say the same and
here you can't you can't guard your h
pawn in the long run so i i i think
another pawn is going to drop here isn't
it yeah you have to be a bit careful as
black white's knight does threaten maybe
to jump into the center of the board
with a check that's why black covers any
potential checks white's knight is
completely frozen white's knight has to
stay on that square to defend its
remaining pawn if that white pawn drops
off the board black has a two-pawn
advantage and that is enough to win the
game so it's all about whether black can
bring the black knight around to win
that white pawn it's still not easy i
mean
so the plan is probably to move the king
and then jump forward with a night off
for a trade
because the king and pawn ending i'm
assuming it's lost i think it depends
where the kings are but i think it's a
draw if white gets the opposition there
yeah okay so you have to be careful when
you offer a trade of knights
yeah so really really
tense position i think black's king
might have to come across anyway and
then the black knight there we go this
is the one you have to stop white's
night uh jumping into that square i
guess then move your knight around and
then do a similar thing is that i guess
that's the plan right yes
it reminds me of an ending which i i
think magnus may have had
a long time ago and i think anish geary
had this against uh
someone in the candidate so you know
it's one of those ones which
seemingly should be quite an easy draw
because there's not much material on the
ball but actually incredibly hard to
play and with one second on the clock
again of course
yeah
wow i think you're right he had this
against uh the young russian yeah that's
right alexenko alexenko alexenko that
was anishkari very similar yeah okay
black's knight is coming it started its
journey towards that white pawn and oh
down to four seconds three seconds two
okay he made it with a few seconds left
and uh now the black knight needs to
find
a route towards that point the one
problem with knights is they don't they
can't lose time they're incapable of
losing tempe so you have to get a
position where white is completely
frozen but you need to move your knight
round to the right square at the right
time when your opponent's pieces are on
the right squares it's still tricky for
magnus to do this
to work out
okay now
no he's covered that square the white
king will have to just wait the white
knight if it moves the pawn drops the
white king has to just sidestep
wow so he has to make his move no other
move you have to bring your king across
there we go he plays it and now black's
king ah is this just genius by magnus
has he found the zugzwang now the white
knight's still stuck if the white king
moves away the blacking goes towards the
white knight it's incredible to watch i
mean it's incredible to watch just just
the understanding yeah and you can see
now white's king is being pushed further
and further away
but he had to get his knight to the
square yeah exactly i was going to say
put this position in your memory banks
you know especially the technique that
he used you know just improving the
placing of his knight to control the
squares of the white king i must admit
this is all fantastic technique to think
he can win the pawn immediately by
giving a check and then retreating the
black knight to attack this white pawn
white's pawn is about to fall it's going
to be two pawns against none and it
still might take a while but that is a
winning end game
yeah it's check oh we played it with one
second again
incredible and uh now the black knight
can step back attacking this white pawn
that pawn is falling and it's important
that the black knight once it captures
that white pawn will defend its own
pawns
and if magnus does win this game then he
only needs a draw in game three to be
ready for the final vladislav artemio he
will have to win both of the two last
rapid games to take it to tie breaks
he's enjoying himself a bit too much
over that move i feel yeah and he's uh
he's going for the more beautiful
zugswang uh and it's one thing i am
amazes me about chess and i love about
chess is you can have brilliant
brilliancies with all the pieces on the
board smashing attacks which are really
visually beautiful but then you can have
these kind of games where there's only a
couple of pieces on the board and
they're just as beautiful but completely
different so there's so much beauty in
chess there's so many different ways and
now he's two pawns up he can uh he he
can just slowly roll those pawns down
the board which which he he's gonna do
now and he's gonna do it with the
assistance of the whole team because the
one danger there is for black is that
the white knight and can swap itself off
for two pawns and that's if that's the
case then it's going to be a draw but of
course black can easily stop this yeah
you have to keep one pawn alive you
can't let the white knight get both of
them
and there we go the white king planting
itself in front of the black pawns you
just have to do this step by step uh for
magnus i would get my king out of the
way soon over the next few moves i don't
really want the black king in the way of
the pawns ideally uh but magnus has a
lot of time on the clock nearly three
minutes and no 50 move rule we should
mention in this one because that will
reset every time black pushes a pawn and
he does that immediately okay so
um i guess it's okay having it's it's
fine here having the king in front of
black's pawns because white knight and
king again they will be stuck at some
point they will have to give way
and yeah it's just a matter of time
right yeah i think yeah i mean he's he's
done
you never relax so this is this is a big
mistake i've made because chess is is
such a stressful game i mean uh i think
arya said it's like doing an exam you
know like an exam you get very stressed
out and it's really hard work on the
mind and as soon as you drop your guard
it's bang you you throw away all that
hard work so only relax when the game's
over and it's so easy to think oh i've
won this now and then just go into
autopilot biggest mistake you can make
that is going to autopilot mode you need
to have that endurance to finish things
off yeah i saw some stats actually that
most car accidents happen within two
miles of reaching your destination and
it's the same with chess most blunders
happen just when you're on the brink of
winning or just on the brink of making a
draw so uh it's yeah it's just that
phenomenon of relaxing too early wow
that's interesting um so okay meanwhile
white's just waiting nothing else to do
with the king black has relocated his
knight
he's ready is it now or over the next
few moves to push a pawn
and magnus just calculating the risk he
just wants to make sure that there are
no stalemates for example
or any night sacrifices by white or any
annoying checks
all right so game three between yana
pomnyacci and andreas penco that has
started napoli actually won game two and
it's up by one point if he wins game
three going on right now he will be
ready for the finals asapenko needs at
least a draw and he also needs to win
either this game or game four to take it
to tie breaks we will jump straight into
that game as soon as this is finished
can it still last for some time this one
still might go for a while i think we
will hit the move 100 mark that i get so
excited
um yeah i mean i'll tell me if he's
doing the right thing he's not resigning
we saw in his body language a few
minutes a few months ago that he's
pretty much given up he knows he's
losing objectively but as we see by
magnus thinking now it's not easy there
are still some tricks left and this is
what i recommend everyone at home never
resign especially in engines like this
there's always resources or always
tricks
that you can set for your opponent to
save the game the number of times when i
was young or especially even now when i
play online in blitz you pre-move or
something and stalemate and the game is
over
and our stats boss asking just messaged
me saying that this is good for magnus's
fighting chess as statistics that we do
know he wants to have a high score on
the fighting chess index and a hundred
moves that's gonna be good for the index
yeah exactly especially if he ends up
winning decisive game yeah yeah so you
must have a massive fighting index with
your 200 or 200 300 move games or
whatever you love doing on a regular
basis it's like
i remember uh dave smurden uh released
stats for i think it was the top hundred
players in the world and i wasn't that
high i was a bit surprised i was a bit
annoyed about that but um
so you're not you're not a fighting
player though i mean
maybe he put the wrong games in maybe he
i i have a grandmaster called howl maybe
he chose that guy but again i remember
one story where you're playing at the
british championships and you're playing
gary lane in the last round and david
only needs a draw to win the british
championships outright and that is a big
title it's something i'd love to have
myself and i know ivanka has won the
british ladies championships many times
but gary offered david a draw quite
quickly
and everyone thought of course you take
the draw you uh become british champion
you hit the bar hard and uh dave was
like no
i just beat him instead
it was
you said no you could become british
champion now and you're like you decided
i was like wow this is incredible so i
was young i was full of optimism
meanwhile there have been some moves we
should mention black is actually giving
up his knight magnus is letting white
take the black knight but that would
distract the white king and the black
pawns are just going to run through and
promote and we see in the evaluation bar
it's completely winning for black now
magnus just needs to choose the right
square phase king
um i'm not sure whether it matters i
mean i would go in front of my pawn here
to be honest but uh yeah i think this
one is winning the black pawns are just
too close to the promotion squares now
yeah i would definitely go in front of
my pawn it looks good and uh let harry
take the glory harry will become a queen
queen harriet harris and uh yeah
actually
this is instructive because knight
struggled most against those flanker
pawns night struggle against harry and
alice uh the most so promote harry here
that's the key harry
harry and harry well will we see uh
harriet the queen or will our time have
give up before that do you think right
he'll give up before then i think it'd
be when it becomes apparent that he
can't uh
maintain well you know he i'll tell me
if he's trying
but uh
simply you can't take the pawn that's
the problem the knight takes pawn you
just give a check with your knight and
king h4 i mean you still have to
calculate that i mean it's the hard way
he's still working things out right yeah
i mean i i would be like okay this this
looks like
still uh you know you've only got one
pawn now and it's like right you have to
be very careful about your calculation
here i mean um
i i'm surprised by this actually i think
magnus is going for something that he's
studied before i've seen this end game
with uh a king and a pawn on this square
and white's knight completely stuck
stopping the black pawn and all you need
to do as black is relocate your knight
distract the white knight and then your
pawn promotes to a queen so i think
magnus
had it worked out pretty much or has
seen something very similar to this
before seeing this pattern yeah it's
incredible again how he just finishes
the game off you know even here it's
like wow he knows this is a win and he's
got it he's got ziggs wang six wang no
matter what white does you will lose the
white knight it's game over and artemiev
i think has just resigned so impressive
it's so impressive in these